if there is
anything that needs to be uh satirized
and remixed
it is trump talking about massive dumps
and by the way extra points if you can
sample
trump saying massive dumps and me
talking about it in a song
please do it
[Music]
[Music]
big massive dumps
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that it was massive dumps that led him
to lose the election
which is just
dumps dumps
dumps dump big massive dumpsters dumps
[Music]
dumps
[Music]
as opposed to once
[Music]
what is going on here what is going what
is going on here
it's just beyond parody massive dumps
cost them the election
what is going on here what is
[Music]
what is going on here what is going on
[Music]
dumps
[Music]
big massive dump
[Music]
all right very very exciting stuff
welcome everybody we are standing by for
joe biden who's going to be
speaking from the state department and
believed uh that he will make some very
very important
uh statements i also am interested in
looking at
the vote about expelling marjorie taylor
green i'm going to be completely honest
with you guys i've been in production
hell all day and i have no idea
when that is supposed to take place can
anyone in chat
tell me it is there a vote scheduled
on marjorie taylor green i would like to
stand back and stand by
for that vote but i don't know exactly
when it's supposed to be
green axed from the education committee
oh it's right now
okay hold on a second let's take a look
then
um
uh marjorie oh here we go here we go
here we go
oh they're voting right now okay on
ordering the pre can somebody
catch me up so i'm guessing that a yes
vote removes her from committees and a
no vote doesn't
and with 217 voting yay
does that does that get us where we need
to be i should be watching some other
stream that would
inform me about this that's correct okay
yeah no maybe so um
i i mean i'm trying to get caught up
here
simple majority removes
right now they're voting on the rules of
the debate oh this is is this is that
true this isn't even the vote
this is just a vote about how they will
debate doing it
or she's removed yeah i'm sorry i'm
trying to figure out what's going on as
much as
some other people in the chat are um
maybe we will get some more information
about that
let's see if uh cbs pbs has some more
information
they don't they're just they've got the
same thing
removed from committees yeah okay this
is just on the rules removal from her
committees or
people are disagreeing there's people
saying this is a vote on removal from
the committees and there's people saying
this is a vote on the rules to debate
removal from the committee
motion to advance to resolution okay
this is a vote for voting we are now
voting to determine how voting will take
place and when voting will take place
okay all right well we're gonna we're
gonna follow this
and um we'll see what's going on
i'm sorry guys i i'm just getting out of
uh
production for the day i definitely am
hearing the sound of victory but i don't
know exactly
where it's coming from right now okay
voting in favor of debating the vote
to vote that's exactly right that's
exactly what's going on
this is okay a kinky turtle just sent a
perfect 10
super chat kinky says this is a vote to
vote on a vote to vote on whether or not
they
should vote to remove her that's that's
exactly right
needless to say this whatever
this vote is is passing okay
um casey says biden already spoke at the
state department yeah no but
he's scheduled to deliver remarks
momentarily the white house has just
gone live with it
and we've got a number of different
streams standing by so we're we're
waiting on that as well and we will be
covering it
very very strongly uh okay
i have so many things to go over with
you guys that i don't even
i don't even know where to start i'm
going to save some of the better ones
for for when more people enter the
stream
um i have been i have to be very careful
in what i said
hold on a second the previous question
is ordered the question is on the
adoption of the resolution
those in favor say aye those opposed say
no
in the opinion of the chairs the eyes
have it speaker
gentleman from oklahoma on that i would
request the a's and the nays
pursuant to section three s of house
resolution eight the
yeas and a's are ordered members will
record their votes by
electronic device
okay so
now do do we know now what they're
voting on
uh hold on wow we already have to ban
somebody jeez
uh i just dropped the banhammer on
someone who said something about me
being a piece of [ __ ] zionist i think
that's an insta-ban that's just i mean
you're that's in the trash
gone absolutely gone
uh oh and our friend nug wrangler is
celebrating the band that's amazing
nug wrangler couldn't have could not
have celebrated the band more quickly
that was insane
as quick i i don't know what's more
impressive how quickly i banned them or
how quickly
nug wrangler was cheering cheering the
band okay
thanks to jack smith who is new member
number one
at joinpacman.com and um i also want to
thank two really great people on twitch
willie b
and bell hair designs who just re-upped
memberships
let's see now what's happening donated
by ms lawrence of michigan pursuant to
atres eight
i informed the house that miss lawrence
will vote yes on a trip okay these are
proxy votes all right
so at some point we're gonna figure out
what they're voting on
um i'm not sure if this is a vote on
voting
or a vote as to whether a vote on voting
will be taking place
or if this is merely a vote as to
whether voting on votes should be
determined
by voting or if these infinite
regressions are not serving anybody
particularly well
so i don't know we're continuing to
follow it
previous vote was to move the resolution
to the floor
this is the vote on the resolution okay
that if that's true that is very very
clear
very very clear um all right
where was i anyway i was on something
what was i oh yeah
i have been invited to participate in a
very special congratulatory video
for a content creator who is very close
to reaching a very
important milestone i believe that to
some degree
it's a surprise so i don't want to say
more but let's just say that very soon
my face or maybe just my voice but i
think they're using my face as well
is going to appear in a very interesting
milestone congratulatory video for
someone okay so that's a an important
announcement
um number two
i did post oh yeah people found this
funny i posted this video to my
instagram yesterday i don't know why i
find this so funny
this a guy got a kim jong-un haircut
and it's so damn funny look at this
i don't know why i find this so funny
[Laughter]
it's unbelievable
anyway so if people want to break from
the more serious stuff that's uh it's
incredibly it's
he's a dead ringer that's on my um
that's on my instagram account okay
um so we are we are monitoring and
standing by for joe biden
we are watching a vote on expelling
marjorie taylor green
from uh committees and
a lot of different things are going on
okay i also have for you guys
i also have for you guys um
yesterday no the day before yesterday
during the stream
i had an idea for a for a song parody
and
it was to do a song with the tune of
jolene
jolene jolene jolene um
and replaced jolene with me saying
vaccine and talking about my experience
with vaccination
and um i got not exactly that but robert
monroe
said hey my band covers jolene so i put
together
vaccine based on your vaccine side
effects
and let's just take a listen to that
this is a submission from robert monroe
vaccine vaccine
vaccine no pain as you are stuck into
my arm right
vaccine vaccine vaccine
vaccine i hope that you won't do me any
harm
the pain began two hours late worried
what medicine i could take the doc said
tylenol's okay with the vaccine
[Music]
shortness of breath i do detect it's
possible that these strong
side effects mean i got covered before i
got the vaccine
no matter how it made me feel in four
weeks i'll roll my shirt up for real and
take
the second dose of the vaccine
vaccine vaccine vaccine vaccine
side effects are not caused
[Music]
soon everyone will be free from
harm beautifully done by robert monroe
very very nice so i like that i
appreciate the i appreciate robert doing
that very nicely done
and we will have much more news on from
the standpoint of vaccines coming
very very soon i do want to say thanks
to brian
steffler who just signed up at
joinpackman.com
my website i would love it if you
signed up at joinpacman.com and i will
thank you profusely if you do
we are standing by for joe but there's
no link to that um robert just sent that
to me maybe we'll make that available at
some point in some way
okay we are um continuing to count votes
via proxy on something related to
marjorie taylor green
i have oh i had a couple different clips
for you guys
here's lindsey graham this is looney
lindsay oh and i'm sorry hold on
let me get let me do a few super chats
we do have some non-trump supporting
rural people in the missouri
ozarks absolutely
hres 91 providing for consideration of
the resolution hres
72 removing a certain member from
certain standing committees
okay previous vote was to move the
resolution to the floor this is the vote
on the resolution
all right so and so presumably this is
actually the vote
on removing marjorie taylor green from
committees
and we have eight minutes left on that
vote okay here's something funny
here's lindsey graham saying you know
there might be
missing context about jewish space
lasers
that would make the comment much less
crazy listen to lindsey
spent some time with her where do you
come down on this idea whether she
should be stripped of committee
assignments
well rather me talking about what she
may have said i want to hear from her
so i flew down to georgia with her on
air force one had a very pleasant
experience with her
very very cordial very pleasant but my
favorite part of this
is lindsey graham saying the word lasers
instead of lasers i love that
here we go but i think she owes herself
quite frankly her
constituents in the country is that true
was she misquoted was she taken out of
context i want to know does she still
believe that
sandy hooks was fake sandy hooks
that 9 11 was an inside job that there's
a jewish laser
laser in the sky starting fires in
california
i don't know i know how words can be
twisted i know how you can
it could have been she that that she
could have meant something different by
a jewish space laser she might have been
saying something about
you know campaign finance reform and it
was just misinterpreted as a jewish
laser be taken out of context
but rather than me talking about her i
would like her to be
definitive did you believe that then
if you've changed your mind why what do
you believe
now then i will comment but i'm going to
give her a chance
to come out and say definitively what
she believes about all these events
it's fun the idea of a jewish space
laser counting as an event is also very
funny
um i don't i don't even know what that
means
uh but anyway that's lindsay coming up
with some way to
not attack or not condemn the things
said by marjorie taylor green
in the past what do you think about
trying to get matt gates to follow
through with his offer to resign and
represent trump in an impeachment
hearing i think he should be encouraged
to do so
no doubt about it do you think any
republicans will vote to suspend
marjorie taylor green from her
committees do they know what shame
is i i don't know has any i'm guessing
none of them yet have voted
to suspend right let's list
are these still proxies that are coming
in by mr bowman pursuant to hres eight i
informed the house that mr bowman will
vote yes
on hres 91
okay so far every republican voting no
um and every democrat voting yes
this is on expelling marjorie taylor
green from her various committees
and we are still monitoring uh for joe
biden who is scheduled to speak
in about eight minutes from the state
department we will continue to monitor
that
okay what else did i have for you guys
uh big thanks to don juan kumquat for
subscribing via twitch prime as well as
brazen three and uh
that is very much appreciated that puts
us
at six today
um do i have any troy york voicemails uh
let me see
troy york voicemails um
oh here's one this one was left at 3 2
a.m
let's listen yeah i'm just wondering why
are you mentioning trump and the slush
fund
he raised for the georgia democrats
uh why are you still talking about trump
and when he lost
and i think you're desperate to get some
anti-trump remarks i think you're gonna
keep talking about trump
you're obsessed with him you suffer from
trump to range syndrome
and what he did is nothing wrong then
trump raised 76 million claimed it was
for fighting voter fraud
and he kept it nothing different than
other
uh charities that do the exact same
thing
but it's not a charity it's trump saying
he was going to win the election that's
not a charity fundraiser
easy money and you're a hypocrite there
are many charities and
lesbian politicians that run and then
they drop out they keep the slush fund
and
you're you're an absolute propagandist
do you
propagandists that's my nickname
actually propagandist
um okay all right so there's that
let's look at oh this is very
interesting i guess
um trump just resigned from
sag-aftra and i guess the letter is
hilarious let's see
i write to you today regarding the
so-called disciplinary committee hearing
aimed at revoking my union membership
who cares
while i'm not familiar with your work
i'm very proud of my work on movies such
as home alone 2
zoolander and wall street
money never sleeps and television shows
including the fresh prince of bel air
saturday night live and of course one of
the most successful shows in television
history
the apprentice just to name a few i've
also greatly helped the cable news
television business said to be a dying
platform with not much time left
until i got involved in politics and
created thousands of jobs
at networks such as msdnc and
fake news cnn among others
which brings me to your blatant attempt
at free media attention to distract from
your dismal record as a union
your organization has done little for
its members and nothing for me it's all
about what have they done for trump
besides collecting dues and promoting
dangerous un-american policies and ideas
as evident by your massive unemployment
rates
and lawsuits from celebrated actors
who even recorded a video asking why
isn't the union fighting for me
this has to be satire the these however
are policy failures your disciplinary
failures are even more egregious i am i
no longer wish to be associated with
your union
as such this letter is to inform you of
my immediate resignation from
sag-aftra you have done nothing for me
that's just that's just amazing i love
that
uh okay so trump resigning from
sag aftra very very important news
and um wow wow wow wow that is really
something else
uh david the coupon code isn't working
oh no
are we really doing this again
the coupon code is working all right let
me let me just show everybody
okay uh you go to joinpakman.com
all right join pacman.com you pick a
membership
monthly or yearly here's how you switch
between the two
let's say i want to go yearly and i want
to do
120 a year okay sign up
all right coupon code let's see coupon
code
better21 perfect
better 21 goes from 120 a year
to 42.22 a year coupon working perfectly
coupon working perfectly couldn't be
working any better all right guys
so if it's not working i hate to use
this phrase because it's sometimes
considered rude
it is user error it's user error
all right yes the coupon codes are legal
yes yes yes
they're legal no but in all seriousness
i would love it if people signed up
we had a tough january from the
standpoint of memberships a lot of
people
uh canceling in fact i got a bunch of
emails stuff like this i get stuff like
this all the time and it makes me sad i
mean it's very much pandemic related
why is it taking so long to load
here it is okay good evening mr pacman
i am sorry good evening mr pacman so
formal
it's unfortunate but i have ended my
membership because i have been
unemployed since march
and my family and i are unsure when
we'll feel it's safe
for me to be a real in a real-life
workplace again i will remain
subscribed to the show's youtube channel
heard from rachel my name is rachel
and i would like to cancel my member
speaking of canceling memberships uh
trump from sag-aftra
i would like to cancel my membership i'm
having financial difficulties
and can't spare the expense of a
long-term
subscription thank you for understanding
and i'm sorry about canceling my
membership
don't apologize to me we are in a
horrible
horrible horrible situation right now
because of the virus
and much struggle much struggle and i
understand
i understand yeah no need to be
apologetic it's your money
that's exactly whoa
today i get to say something that brings
me
tremendous happiness president biden
vice president harris welcome to the
state department
for more than two decades i've had the
privilege of watching
president biden at work i've seen his
commitment to the american people
his expertise in foreign policy his
steadfast
belief in diplomacy and his rock-solid
support
for our diplomats and development
experts
i've seen them on the hill in the oval
office
in distant world capitals from baghdad
to bagram
paris to peoria and
visiting our troops visiting our
diplomats
visiting all the men and women
representing this country and i can say
without fear of contradiction that in
the history
of the presidency no one has brought as
much foreign policy experience to the
job
as joe biden wow wherever he goes he's
been a champion
for american leadership and a defender
of american values
and in kamala harris he has a vice
president
we have a vice president with a long
track record
of standing up for the security of the
american people
and an abiding commitment to using
diplomacy to advance our interests
and defend our values around the world
at this moment of unprecedented global
challenge
it's more important than ever that the
united states
show up and lead because the world
simply doesn't organize itself to solve
big problems
and the well-being of the american
people hangs in the balance
we need diplomacy to get the pandemic
under control worldwide
to save american lives and livelihoods
we need diplomacy to address the climate
crisis to protect communities
across our country we need diplomacy to
check the rise of authoritarianism
to prevent the spread of dangerous
weapons to shore up democracy
to defend human rights all of which
makes the world more stable and free
and all of which protects the security
and prosperity of the american people
foreign policy is domestic policy and
because our strength at home determines
our strength in the world
domestic policy is foreign policy too
president biden and vice president
harris know this better than anyone
that's why they believe so strongly in
the work that we do
at the state department and they've made
it clear that the first question
we must ask ourselves here at state is
how will this benefit our fellow
americans
how will this policy answer their needs
how will this outreach reflect
their values how will this initiative
make their lives
just a little bit better right we're
going to hold ourselves to that standard
every step of the way president biden
and vice president paris have come here
today
at the very start of their
administration
to make sure we know that we have their
support
and that means a great deal to all of
the men and women
of the state department we will do our
best mr president madam vice president
to make you proud and with that it is my
pleasure to introduce the president of
the united states
joe biden
wow
a little bit of a cleaning there
there we go a little wipe there
all right
mr secretary it's great to be here with
you
and i've been looking forward a long
time to be able to call you mr secretary
good afternoon everyone it's an honor to
be back at the state department
under the eyes of the first american
chief diplomat
benjamin franklin and by the way i want
you all to know in the press i was the
benjamin franklin professor of
presidential politics at penn
and i thought they did that because i
was as old as he was
but i guess not anyway all kidding aside
it's great to be here and stand
alongside our most recent
senior diplomat secretary tony blinken
mr secretary thank you for welcoming us
today that was a dad joke we've worked
together for over 20 years
diplomatic skills are respected equally
by your friends
and our competitors around the world and
they know
when you speak you speak for me and so
so is the message i want the world to
hear today
america is back america
is back diplomacy is back
at the center of our foreign policy as i
said in my inaugural address
we will repair our alliances and engage
with the world once again not to meet
yesterday's challenges
but today's and tomorrow's american
leadership
must meet this new moment of advancing
authoritarianism including the growing
ambitions of china
to rival the united states and the
determination of russia
to damage and disrupt our democracy we
must meet the new moment accelerating
glow of
accelerating global challenges from the
pandemic
to the climate crisis to nuclear
proliferation challenging
the will only to be solved by nations
working together
and in common we can't do it alone that
must be this we must start with
diplomacy
rooted in america's most cherished
democratic values
defending freedom championing
opportunity
upholding universal rights respecting
the rule of law and treating every
person with dignity
that's the grounding wire of our global
policy our global power
that's our inexhaustible source of
strength
that's america's abiding advantage
though many of these values have come
under intense pressure
in recent years even pushed to the brink
in the last few weeks the american
people are going to emerge from this
moment stronger more determined and
better equipped to unite the world
in fighting to defend democracy because
we have fought for it ourselves
over the past few days we've been in
close cooperation with our allies and
partners to bring together the
international community
to address the military coup in burma
i've also been in touch with leader
mcconnell to discuss
our shared concerns about the situation
in burma
and we are united in our resolve
there can be no doubt in a democracy
force should never seek to overrule the
will of the people or attempt
to erase the outcome of a credible
election
[Music]
the burmese military should relinquish
power they have seized released the
advocates
and activists and officials they have
detained
lift the restrictions on
telecommunications
and refrain from violence
as i said earlier this week we will work
with our partners to support restoration
of democracy and the rule of law and
the subtitles are like two minutes
delayed i don't know why
over the past two weeks
of many of our closest friends
canada mexico the uk germany france
nato japan south korea australia
to being re-forming the habits
of cooperation and rebuilding the muscle
of democratic alliances that have
atrophied
over the past few years of neglect and i
would argue abuse
america and alliances are our greatest
asset
and leading with diplomacy means
standing
shoulder to shoulder with our allies and
key partners
once again by leading with diplomacy we
must also mean
engaging our adversaries and our
competitors diplomatically
where it's in our interest and advance
the security
of the american people that's why
yesterday the united states and russia
agreed to extend the new start treaty
for five years
to preserve the only remaining treaty
between our countries
safeguarding nuclear stability
at the same time i made it clear to
president putin
in a manner very different from my
predecessor that the days of the united
states rolling over
in the face of russia's aggressive
actions interfering with our elections
cyber attacks poisoning its citizens are
over we will not hesitate to raise the
cost on russia
and defend our vital interests and our
people
and we will be more effective in dealing
with russia
when we work in coalition and
coordination
with other like-minded partners
the politically motivated jailing of
alexi
navalny and the russian efforts to
suppress freedom of expression and
peaceful assembly
are a matter of deep concern to us and
the international community
mr navalny like all russian citizens is
entitled to his rights
under the russian constitution he's been
targeted
targeted for exposing corruption he
should be released immediately and
without condition
we'll also take on directly the
challenges posed
by our prosperity security and
democratic values by
our most serious competitor china
will confront china's economic abuses
counter its aggressive coercive action
to push back
on china's attack on human rights
intellectual property
and global governance but we are ready
to work with beijing
when it's in america's interest to do so
we will compete from a position of
strength
by building back better at home working
with our allies and partners
renewing our renewing our role in
international institutions
and reclaiming our credibility and moral
authority
much of which has been lost that's why
we move quickly to begin restoring
american engagement internationally
and earn back our leadership position
to catalyze global action on shared
challenges
on day one i signed the paperwork
to rejoin the paris climate agreement
we're taking steps led by an example of
integrating climate objectives across
all of our diplomacy and raise the
ambition
of our climate targets that way we can
challenge
other nations other major emitters up to
to up the ante
on their own commitments i'll be hosting
climate leaders
climate leaders summit to address the
climate crisis
on earth day of this year america must
lead in the face of this existential
threat
and just as with the pandemic it
requires global cooperation
we've also re-engaged with the world
health organization
that way we can build better global
preparedness to counter covet 19
as well as detect and prevent future
pandemics because there will be more
we've elevated the status of cyber
issues within our government
including appointing the first national
the deputy national security advisor for
cyber
and emerging technology we're launching
an
urgent initiative to improve our
capability readiness and resiliency i
told you the stream was urgent
cyberspace
today i'm announcing additional steps
to course correct our foreign policy and
better unite our democratic values
with our diplomatic leadership to begin
sec defense secretary austin will be
leading a global posture review
of our forces so that our military
footprint is appropriately aligned
with our foreign policy and national
security priorities
it will be coordinated across all
elements of our national security
with secretary austin and secretary
blinken working in close cooperation
and while this review is taking place
we'll be stopping any planned troop
withdrawals from germany
we're also stepping up our diplomacy to
end the war in yemen
a war which has created humanitarian and
strategic catastrophe this is big
i've asked my middle east team to ensure
our support for the united nations led
initiative to impose a ceasefire
open humanitarian challenge and restore
long dormant peace talks this morning
secretary blinken appointed tim
lenderking
a career foreign policy officer as our
special
envoy to the yemen conflict and i
appreciate him doing this
tim as a life has lifelong experience in
the region
and he'll work with the un envoy and all
parties of the conflict
to push for a diplomatic resolution
and tim's diplomacy will be bolstered by
usi usaid
working to ensure that humanitarian aid
is reaching the yemeni people
who are suffering and undurable
unendurable devastation
this war has to end and to underscore
our commitment we are ending all
american support for offensive
operations and the war in yemen
including relevant arms should have been
done a long time ago at the same time
saudi arabia faces missile attacks uav
strikes
and other threats from iranian supply
forces in multiple countries
we're going to continue to support and
help saudi arabia defend its sovereignty
and its territorial integrity and its
people
we also face a crisis of more than 80
million displaced people suffering all
around the world
the united states moral leadership on
refugee issues
was a point of bipartisan consensus for
so many decades when i first
got here we shined the light of lamp on
of liberty on oppressed people we
offered safe havens for those fleeing
violence or
persecution and our example pushed other
nations doing too much guys right
they're doors as well
so today i'm also an idiot an executive
order
to begin the hard work of restoring our
refugee admissions program
to help meet the unprecedented global
need
it's going to take time to rebuild what
has been so badly damaged
but that's precisely what we're going to
do
this executive order will position us to
be able to raise the refugee admissions
back up to 125 000 persons
for the first full fiscal year of the
biden harris administration
and i'm directing the state department
to consult with congress
about making a down payment on that
commitment as soon as possible
and to further repair our moral
leadership i'm also
issuing a presidential memo to agencies
to reinvigorate our leadership
on the lgbtqi issues and do it
internationally
you know we'll ensure diplomacy and
foreign assistance are working to
promote the rights
of those individuals included by
combating criminalization and protecting
lgbtq refugees and asylum
seekers finally to successfully
reassert our diplomacy and keep
americans safe
prosperous and free we must restore the
health and morale of our foreign policy
institutions
i want the people who work in this
building
and our embassies and councils around
the world to know
i value your expertise and i respect you
and i will have your back
this administration is going to empower
you to do your jobs
not target or politicize you
we want a rigorous debate that brings
all perspectives and makes room for
dissent
that's how we'll get the best possible
policy outcomes
so with your help the united states will
again lead
not just by the example of our power but
the power of our example
that's why my administration has already
taken the important step
to live our domestic values at home our
democratic values at home
within hours of taking office i signed
an executive order
overturning the hateful discriminatory
muslim ban
reverse the ban on transgender
individuals serving in our military
as part of our commitment to truth
transparency accountability
we stated on day one we started in day
one with
daily briefings of the press from the
white house
we've rinsed we've reinstituted regular
briefings here at state
at the pentagon we believe
a free press isn't an adversary
rather it's essential a free press is
essential
to the health of a democracy we've
restored our commitment to science
and to create policies grounded in facts
and evidence
i suspect ben franken would approve
we've taken steps to acknowledge and
address systemic racism
and the scourge of white supremacy in
our own country
that it was scourge shall echo you will
not just be an issue that's a joke by
the way for one department in our
administration
it has to be the business of the whole
of government and
all our federal policies and
institutions
all this matters to foreign policy
because when we host
the summit of democracies early in my
administration
to rally the nations of the world to
defend democracy globally
to push back the authoritarianism is
advanced
we'll be much more credible partner
because of these efforts to show up our
own foundations
there's no longer a bright line between
foreign and domestic policy
every action we take in our conduct
abroad
we must take with american working
families in mind
advancing a foreign policy for the
middle class demands
urgent focus on our domestic economic
economic renewal
and that's why i immediately put forth
the american rescue plan
to pull us out of this economic crisis
that's why i signed an executive order
strengthening our buy american policies
last week
that's also why i work with congress to
make
far-reaching investments in research and
development of transformative
and transformative technologies
these investments jobs maintain
america's competitive edge globally and
ensure
all americans share in the dividends
if we invest in ourselves and our people
if we fight to ensure that american
businesses are positioned
to compete for national global stage if
the rules of international trade
aren't stacked against us if our workers
and intellectual property are protected
then there's no country on earth not
china or
any other country on earth that can
match us
investing in our diplomacy isn't
something we do just because it's the
right thing
to do for the world we do it in order to
live in peace security and prosperity
we do it because it's in our own naked
self-interest
when we strengthen our alliances we
amplify our power
as well as our ability to disrupt
threats before they can reach our shores
when we invest in economic development
of countries
we create new markets for our products
and reduce the likelihood
of instability violence and mass
migrations
when we strengthen health systems in far
regions of the world we reduce the risk
of future pandemics
that can threaten our people on our
economy when we defend
equal rights of people the world over of
women and girls lgbtq
individuals indigenous communities and
people with disabilities
the people of every ethnic background
and religion
we also ensure that those rights are
protected for our own children here in
america
america cannot afford to be absent any
longer on the world stage
i come today to the state department an
agency as old and historic as a nation
itself
because diplomacy has always been
essential to how american
america writes its own destiny
for the diplomacy of ben franklin helped
assure the success of our revolution
the vision of the marshall plan helped
prevent the world from floundering on
the wreckage of war
and the passions of eleanor roosevelt
declared the audacious idea
of universal rights that belong to all
the leadership of diplomats of every
stripe
doing the daily work of engagement
created the very idea of a free
and interconnected world we are a
country that does big
things american diplomacy makes it
happen
and our administration is ready to take
up the mantle and lead once again
thank you all may god bless you and
protect our troops our diplomats
and our development experts and all
americans serving in harm's way
okay joe biden at the state department
for getting his mask there i guess but
hedy off heading off
there is vice president kamala harris
secretary of state anthony blinken
behind them
and uh there it is so we are standing by
we are so close to knowing
whether the house of representatives
will be expelling marjorie taylor greene
from her committee assignments in the
house of representatives
for such comments as there is a jewish
control
controlled space laser used to start
forest fires um and we are
standing by nine votes remaining nine
votes remaining
and uh correct me if i'm wrong it's 218
that is needed four of the remaining
nine votes would need to go for yay
in order to expel marjorie taylor greene
we're standing
by with that uh okay i have
so many other things to go over and to
talk about with you first that first and
foremost
oh we missed sev yeah yeah people are
pointing out what happened to
seven seven seven seven seven
last stream we were very close on twitch
to 77
777 followers and now we're already past
it
i know it would have been fun i guess
for it to happen while we were on stream
but we are now at seven
seven eight six zero so forget about
quintuple seven we're just going for a
hundred thousand
okay so that's what's happening on
twitch and
what's the most sub yeah this is the
most we've never had more than 25 95
twitch subs
ever so this right now you are
witnessing history we've never had uh
never had more than that i'm uh i'm in a
documentary film that's just been
released
which i'm going to tell you guys about
and then maybe some of you will want to
watch it it's uh available on youtube
i'm going to look at the trailer
momentarily i appear in a documentary
with anthony scaramucci and dilbert's
scott adams can you imagine we'll get to
that
in a moment i do want to say thanks to a
bunch of people who just signed up on my
website okay
give me just a moment to thank some
people caitlyn
phillips is a new member at
joinpakman.com
steven zuowar is a new member
kathleen farley has signed up paul
elfering
is a new member i want to say thanks to
thomas ponce
and daniel frey as well as
justin kepper and toby phillips
and lastly trudy mclaughlin i appreciate
all nine of you very very much whoa
what's going on here
um there we go thank you very much
uh we are two yay votes away
from uh marjorie taylor green being
expelled
from committees being expelled from
committees
let's just keep it here for a moment
i'll just load up
this uh trailer just so we've got it
ready
and we're going to go to that in a
moment but we are standing by here
very very very very close vote as you
can see
six votes left two of them need to go to
yes and marjorie taylor greene
will be expelled from her committee
assignments
in the house of representatives wild
times
h.r 91 is only for the consideration of
h.r 72 oh so this isn't the vote i
thought this was the vote
now people are telling me this is not
the vote
hold on a second h.r 91
are you kidding me i thought we already
had a vote on voting
you have got to be kidding me
can we clarify i was under the
impression that the previous vote was
about voting
and that this is now the vote
are people messing with me this can't
because is that actually what's going on
this is the vote for sure people are
saying
the first vote was whether to vote and
this is the vote
we haven't voted on voting on voting i
know
voting on voting pass this is the vote
wow can you imagine if this isn't really
the vote
wow next they'll have to vote to certify
this vote right i mean you still have to
do that
yeah you have to vote to accept the vote
to imagine if 218 vote yes
but then only 216 vote to accept that
vote
it would be uh it would be a real big
mess um
okay all right so we're standing by i
think ryan is messing with me
chalkway pitchford says david it seems
your viewership hasn't dipped after
trump maybe it wasn't him
maybe we all like you you know it's very
very interesting i was just looking at
numbers because
for years it's been very popular for
people to show up and say that the show
is circling the drain is often the term
that's used
and i was looking at um our
view numbers and i saw that in
in november we had 54 million views on
youtube which is just
nuts and then in december we had
45 million views which is expected
december typically
slows down but then in january we also
had 44 million views i
expected a dramatic slowdown in january
just because a lot of people are going
to check out of politics
january was just this big um
so who knows it seems people are staying
to some degree i don't know i mean i
don't know what to tell you but it's all
it's all it's all exciting that's
happening i i can assure you of that
okay we are standing by for those final
votes let's look here is me
featured in a a documentary film by
james fletcher
called the accidental president i
uh appear right at the beginning of the
trailer
it's only a minute and a half trailer
let's look at it
it was a perfect storm really you saw
that right that was me i think most
people did see him as a joke yeah don't
don't blink i'm gonna have to go back
this is just the trailer i'm in i'm
i'm in the mid the film more than half a
second but let's just go back
because it's real quick there
it was a perfect storm really yeah i was
unsure about that doing the really i was
at first i thought you know i was
thinking about like what's my
character's motivation in this
and i was gonna say it was a perfect
storm and just leave it
but as i workshop this with my acting
coach i was like now i should add
something else so that's why i went with
the more
i'm sorry with the really it was a
perfect storm really
all right one more time
it was a perfect storm really from the
very beginning
i think most people did see him as a
joke
[Applause]
this is a tv star who knew how to work
the medium of television
he was the first smash mouth shock job
candidate
quiet a lot of americans like that stuff
he had a resonance transcended logic
it was emotional he just said whatever
came to his mind
crude hypocritical dishonest that's
already baked into your understanding of
who he is
trump can survive the unsurvivable and
we'll raise you
four or five clinton accusers
as long as we keep responding as an
audience
that's how they're gonna try to win
elections
has our political framework changed you
can't go back now
the public has changed politics has
changed
how does donald trump win
how does he not win right
so it's available right now on youtube
if people if people are interested you
can check it out it is uh it's
it's a great film actually and james
fletcher the the producer director was
really great now
you might have just just to go back one
more time because you might have missed
my presence in the uh
in the trailer here it is just once more
it was a perfect storm really
[Laughter]
all right so there it is um check it out
though it's it's very very good stuff
and uh people people may people may like
it all right very very good
uh okay um we are still standing by for
these last six votes
i guess on expelling marjory taylor
green from committees
and uh okay here we go david hr 91 is
shown here
all right legiscan let's see
here what is hr h res 91
all right sets forth the rules for
consideration of h res 72
removing a certain member for certain
standing committees of the house of
representatives
wow so it this actually might only be
the vote
on voting oh my god can you imagine
let's see so hr 70 i think people i
think it's actually true this isn't the
vote
okay hres72
um this resolution removes marjorie
taylor green from the house
they're really j they're really just
voting on the rules oh my god
i can't so this is not the vote to expel
this is the vote to approve the rules on
how to debate
whether to expel but yeah so what was
the
what was the vote before that doesn't
make any sense
was the vote before about whether they
were going to be voting on
how they should debate whether to vote
is that act that actually seems to be
what it was
i'm shocked that it's kafka-esque yeah
the vote on the vote on the vote
it's pronounced chokwe okay i'm sorry i
apologize thank you
um voting on starting the vote
on whether you should debate it one way
or the other
seems absolutely insane to me it really
does
i i'm i'm actually aghast that that's
what's going on
yeah okay all right well anyway it seems
soon they will be deciding
whether they can start debating whether
to remove marjorie taylor green
uh from the uh from from the committees
all right very good
okay let's just go through the other
things i had for you guys okay
um oh a big thank you to m santali for
gifting a twitch sub
as well as blief and
ravlin that is an additional we've got
an additional eight folks who just
subbed on twitch and i really appreciate
that
um okay before i move on to some other
things let me just real quick go through
some of these super chats
uh the movie opens with david doing a
bluetooth commercial yeah i should have
said it was a perfect storm really
sponsored by bluechew fda approved
as the white house turns keeps us on our
toes and listening
david in the coming months are you
planning on doing segments on news from
other countries like farm law protests
in india
you know those segments do terribly like
disastrously
we almost because our audience is so
heavily us-based
so i'm not sure about that
smartmatic has sued fox and giuliani
do you find trumpism akin to nazism not
in the literal but in the sense of its
nationalism conspiratorial thinking
racism and ultra capitalism
there are certainly overlaps yeah i mean
there are certainly but but you know we
don't want to say trumpism is nazism we
want to be real careful
from the standpoint of storms it was
perfect really
yeah i agree i agree
okay let me get to a few other things
case numbers case numbers are coming
down
really fast from the perspective of
negative
okay case numbers are down an average
of 42 percent from the peak and the peak
was only three weeks ago
let's keep it going let's keep this
going
unfortunately deaths so far are not yet
coming down
they have leveled out and my expectation
would be
that deaths will start coming down as
far as vaccinations
are concerned the u.s the world has now
given out 108 million shots
of that a 35 million have been given out
in the united states
we are up to 1.34 million doses per day
in the united states and that's a very
very good thing
okay what else did i have um
oh this was a weird thing that happened
on newsmax just the low production value
of newsmax i continue to find funny
check this out uh minority leader
mccarthy was there chairman brady that's
uh
several of us and uh to hear the
heart-wrenching stories of these
pipeline companies that have to tell
thousands of their their employees
they're now laid off
because of executive orders by this new
president
it is unbelievable what we're seeing and
you're the quote by by bernie sanders
oh man
[Music]
i love that there's another really funny
one which was the trump audio trouble
trump audio problems
there's some really funny these had me
cracking up not that long ago let me see
if they come up here
um
those are the heroes that the left and
the democrats
okay no that's that's judge jeanine
having a problem where was this
these are some of the funniest videos
give me a second it's worth looking for
this because these are so
funny i know i covered them
um let me see here
trump rally
audio engineer let me see if i can find
this no that's not coming uh trump audio
problem uh
i think i might have this trump no there
it is
it must have been before yeah it must
have been before the election
so let me see here these are just so
funny oh here it is here it is this is
my favorite
the i i was laughing hysterically
watching this by myself when this
when this all happened check this out
[Laughter]
i don't know why i find that so funny i
think it's trump's frustration with it
olivia states
the bike
[Music]
[Applause]
these guys yeah that's right you can't
maybe uh
now it's probably a rhino is operating
isn't that the best and then there's one
more of these
hold on uh there was one more
hold on i it was this exact same event
uh let me find the other one
okay here's more oh oh here here i have
the link here's another set another
audio problem
where trump attacks the audio engineer
and our incredible oh these people don't
know what the hell
oh that's just the best these people
don't know what the hell they're doing
the i think it's funnier because of how
derailed he gets
let's listen to it once more and are
incredible
oh these people don't know what the hell
they're doing
let me recover my ears for one second
oh man i this i'm going to miss this is
good old-fashioned fun
whoever did this microphone don't pay
him
well now see the funny thing is that's
not a joke
trump doesn't pay his lawyers that
that's for real
there's no joke about that part you know
i have a reputation for not paying
and it's a false reputation when
somebody does a lousy job
like a microphone that's no good or like
teleprompters that fly with the wind
this guy it's unbelievable
i say don't pay him but we love our
incredible hispanic american
right the audio engineers are bad
hispanics we love let me just see one
more here
and are incredible oh these people don't
know what the hell they're doing that's
that's gold i mean you can't you can't
write stuff that's that uh
it's that [ __ ] he's such a terrible
person exactly that's the real takeaway
with uh with all of that all right thank
you very much glad i'm
thanks for indulging me in and being
able to find that and also thanks to jc
for signing up at uh at joinpakman.com
very much appreciate that
uh thank you okay a couple of other
things let's see what else i had for you
oh oh oh
i have some lauren beaubert clips she
gave
what i think by some very narrow
technical definition might count as an
interview to fox news
and um this is someone who has no
business you know
i don't even want to sit like i was
going to say this is someone who has no
business teaching preschool
or working at a grocery store but i
don't want to insult anybody in those
positions
i don't know how this person uh balances
a checkbook okay take a listen to this
you have alexandria ocasio-cortez
accusing senator
cruz of of nearly but i've never heard
that pronunciation
zinedine has anyone heard that i've not
i don't
i'm not even making fun of an acc i've
just never heard of zinedar
senator cruz of nearly murdering her or
comparing
congressman chip roy's actions to a
sexual
abuser this is ridiculous and someone at
some time needs to hold them accountable
and maybe it's the freshman class right
and then she also went on to say the
following
and so the d triple c can throw whatever
they want at me
it's not going to stick i'll keep
whacking down the moles and
you're exactly right uh we can't just
keep sacrificing
republicans to the d triple c into the
democrat party
they will look after their their next
head
i mean i i just want to make this very
clear to everyone watching now
we have to translate washington to the
rest of the country every night
no you need to translate reality for
lauren beaubert to understand it it's
not no no
it's i love how laura ingram's like oh
you know lauren you're speaking a little
bit too higher level for a lot of people
they don't understand this stuff no
lauren beaubert doesn't understand a
damn thing and and the world needs to be
explained to her
with all due respect it's not about you
it's not true
congresswoman green it's not it's not
about any one of you
this is about trying to take out anyone
ever connected to donald trump because
they don't want to have to spend that
much money again to meet someone like
him in 2024
that means take out anyone connected
with him
they said it's a third of the republican
party or third of the country still
supports his ideas
it's about the issue of 218 and then
acer 210
the resolutions are adopted without
objection the motion reconsider is laid
on the table
okay so now do they start debate
for what purpose does the gentleman from
texas seek recognition
the move to adjourn the question is on
the motion
those in favor say aye those opposed say
no
the nose have it the motion is not
adopted mr speaker
texas i would ask for the a's and a's oh
my god through the section three
s of house resolution eight that
yesterday
are ordered members will record their
votes by electronic device so if i
understand correctly guys
they now democrat oh my god it's like
what what are we doing with our tax
money the
um that's not a joke i
here's what just happened okay
first they voted apparently on whether
to vote on the rules for
debating whether to expel marjorie
taylor green
okay then they voted
to accept the democrats had the majority
they voted
to accept the rules for the debate
about whether to expel marjorie taylor
green from committees
when that passed a republican
stood up and said let's adjourn so
what's the goal is
fine democrats won we're going to have
to debate it but let's not do it let's
end
for the day there was an objection
they voted they're not a judge a lot of
people voted
no we don't want to adjourn knowing that
there's a democratic majority
the speaker said the nose have it by ear
and
understanding and a republican now
says no no no no the voice vote isn't
enough
i want a vote about whether to adjourn
so my guess now is 218
democrats will vote no we're not
adjourning
the next step is to now have the debate
after which there will be a vote about
whether
to expel marjorie taylor green from the
committees
i don't even know if now this is
expected to be happening to does anyone
know like will this actually happen
today
yeah i i don't even think the voice i
mean listen the voice vote is fine when
it's like
you know ninety percent um these are
stall tactics of course
i think it's also crazy that you need 15
minutes to vote and then it takes even
longer but i know because of covid
you know all this different this is
absolutely nuts
i know that this happens all the time i
know guys listen i'm doing a show here
okay
the question isn't the process but why
it takes 15 minutes to click the buttons
yeah i know
i know it's it's unbelievable uh okay
let's just get to that last little bit
of lauren beaubert though here oh hell
that wasn't it
here it is that's what they want to
brand as ray sister white supremacist
even though they were quite popular
uh among uh various minority groups
laura you are absolutely right okay yeah
so anyway so that's that we got that out
of the way
um oh and here's one more here's kevin
mccarthy
this is so funny kevin mccarthy used to
say there's no place for q anon in the
republican party and then yesterday he
said he doesn't even know what it is and
called it cuon
this is so funny check this out well let
me be very clear
there is no place for q on on in the
republican party i do
not support it and then why did you tell
us you walked around with the bible
looking for reps to leave at omar
saying that they needed to swear on the
bible and not the quran
like how do you how are you going to
deal look
our party is very diverse you mentioned
two people who are going to join our
party and both of them have denounced
cuon
so i think it would be helpful if you
could hear exactly what she told all of
us denouncing
kuwan i don't know if i say it right i
don't even know what it is uh well it's
weird because
just a few months ago he was on fox news
talking about it and he seemed to know a
lot about it so now he says cue he
doesn't know what q1 is anymore
weird really weird dude very very
strange guy
all right i'm closing out a bunch of
different things that we are going
through
um and i think we've mostly got
everything
here um okay all right good and then i i
do have a tucker carlson clip to review
and i will do that uh momentarily
um oh no guys the
the coop i'm begging i'm begging you the
coupon code is working okay
the coupon code is working if maybe
you're trying to use it on some other
website
we just went through this okay i just
tried the coupon code okay
i typed in better21 it dropped the
membership from 120 a year to 42.22
the coupon code is working i promise you
i promise it
really is guys it's working it's working
okay the coupon code's fine there's no
issue
there's no issue with the coupon code um
okay let me let me review some uh it is
illegal oh the coupon code is immoral
and illegal to accept such a serious
discount
it's you you should definitely question
your ethics but it's working from a
technical standpoint
okay the u.s is a backwater theocracy
why are you constantly surprised by this
malfeasance from your elected
representatives
uh i don't know that's a fair question
it seems like a kind of a filibuster via
redundant vote counting yeah that's
exactly what it is
that's absolutely what they're doing
let's spend the money to employ pipeline
workers for a u.s pipeline for water
from places with plenty or pre-flood to
places that need it
okay how is joe biden's impeachment
going yeah
it's stalled marjorie taylor green
drafting articles of impeachment of joe
biden
and then it it didn't go any further how
much do you
how much of a threat do you think
christian nationalism
is to the united states it's a threat
but it's it's sort of like how much is a
threat is trump to the u.s well
if the republican electorate wasn't so
uh
bamboozlable that they would have voted
for him trump as a candidate wouldn't be
a threat
unfortunately republicans fell for it so
it that makes it a threat and in that
sense christian nationalism
is a threat uh no no question about it
um okay
so do we have any
idea does anybody have a serious answer
as to whether
the actual vote on expelling margaery
taylor green from committees
will happen today do we have any idea
about that
because i was hoping to cover that and
yet i don't know how many votes on
voting on voting on voting we're going
to have
we don't know
it'll happen tomorrow low to zero chance
that it happens today
should we have a vote as to whether we
should vote on whether it will happen
today
no it didn't people think they've
already voted on that they have not
it has not been voted on yet it has not
been voted on yet
uh okay it seems like it's at least
gonna be a little bit and there may be
even be a long period of debate okay in
that case i'm good this stream was to
cover biden at the state department so
i'm going to end
this stream here and then i've got a ton
of work to do i will monitor
if debate actually starts on expelling
her and it looks like it's going to
happen today
i'll reset a new uh stream
and then i'll see you guys back here so
i'll be monitoring it i'm glad you
joined me today and i may see you i mean
probably seems like maybe at some point
in a couple of hours all right thanks
everybody